racism and xenophobia are unfortunately
everywhere however one woman is turning
this into this meet Germany's hate
destroyer in Germany a former teacher
amela menses Rahm has made her life
mission to remove any neo-nazi stickers
and graffiti around her country it's no
easy feat though nine and how does one
arm oneself for a war against street 8
medium parent a travel or then a
collection fan order evening father mel
has been covering removing and obscuring
these messages since the eighties she
keeps a record of everything she's wiped
out all over her country said Vicki
Janowitz Mitra's until you have a
receiver you busy Monday please Allison
food fanatic about comma every day
except for Sunday's her Mela packs her
bags and heads off to the streets
sometimes she now's a big one like this
heart it used to be a swastika other
times it's small but even the crudest
message doesn't slip by my new short
side violated Oh Prague the sphere
Thunder Nazi [ __ ] hide - Houdini
Topanga that fatso me taboo and
achievement in yet in had septa do yoga
marketed Islamic they're shocked -
leyland it would take first to admit
difficulty defeated and as long as as
hate in this world our mela will be
there can in hand and if we stand a
decent man is and how is the comment on
the u.s. hurt after cheaters alert the
site each tab indicates miles of freedom
[Music]
you
[Music]